From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Every morning when I wake up, at some point in time through the morning, those numbers are the first things that pop in my head. And it's been over two and a half years, but I still think of those numbers every day. They're not any significant numbers for the fact of I didn't even pick the numbers. I let the computer pick them. But they're etched in my mind. 3, 8, 9, 37, 38, 48.
每天早上醒来，在上午的某个时间点，那些数字总是第一个蹦进我脑海的东西。距离中奖已经两年半多了，但我每天还是会想到那些数字。它们其实并不是什么有意义的数字，我甚至都没亲自选号，是让电脑随机选的。但它们就像刻在我的脑子里一样。3、8、9、37、38、48。
Not that long ago, Todd Powell won $27 million from the Florida State Lottery. Up until that point, he made his living working long hours in the ice and snow on the Alaska pipeline. He sat on the bed the morning he won watching them draw the numbers on television, his bags packed to head north to Alaska.
不久前，托德·鲍威尔在佛罗里达州彩票中赢了2700万美元。在那之前，他一直在阿拉斯加输油管道的冰天雪地里辛苦工作谋生。中奖那天早上，他坐在床上看着电视直播开奖，行李都已经打包好准备前往阿拉斯加。
I tried to wake my wife up to tell her that I'd hit the lottery. And when I woke her up, she thought I was fibbing to her. She grabbed the comforter and threw it over her head and just didn't want to hear it. And I told her, I said, well, if you will look at my heart, you can tell that I'm not fibbing to you. And you could actually see it in my neck beating. And I felt like it was just fixing to bounce clean out of my chest.
我试着叫醒我妻子，告诉她我中了彩票。当我叫醒她时，她以为我在骗她。她抓起被子蒙住头，根本不想听。我跟她说，我说，如果你看着我的心，你就能看出我没有骗你。你甚至能看到我脖子上的动脉在跳动。我觉得它快要从我胸口跳出来了。
Money changes things. And a lot of money changes a lot of things. People Todd had known his whole life were nervous talking with him. Strangers wrote asking for money, sometimes for a lot of money. There were family troubles.
钱会改变一切。而大笔的钱会改变很多事情。托德认识了一辈子的人在和他交谈时都感到局促不安。陌生人写信来要钱，有时要的数额还很大。家庭也出现了矛盾。
Right after the lottery, the woman that I was married to just-- I started seeing changes, dramatic changes. And the fact that she kind of looked at it a little different than I. We had only been married seven months. And she just looked at it as, well, there was this big pile of money there that I can just do whatever I want to with it.
彩票中奖后，我和当时结婚的那个女人……我开始看到变化，剧烈的变化。事实上，她看待这件事的角度和我有些不同。我们当时才结婚七个月。她只是觉得，那有一大笔钱，我可以随心所欲地用它做任何我想做的事。
He couldn't sleep at night, couldn't eat, lost 26 pounds. He only weighed 154 when he won the lottery. There were fights over money with his wife. They got divorced. He lent friends money who not only never paid it back, they avoided him. They got indignant when he asked for the money, saying he couldn't possibly miss a few thousand bucks. It changes you, all that.
他晚上睡不着，吃不下饭，瘦了26磅。中奖时他才154磅。他和妻子因为钱吵架。他们离婚了。他借钱给朋友，结果对方不仅从不还钱，还躲着他。当他开口要钱时，他们甚至表现得很愤慨，说他不可能缺这几千块钱。这一切都改变了你。
I may have gotten a little harder. I don't know, because a lot of times now, when people start with the bleeding heart stuff, you know what's fixing to follow. And it kind of just makes you where your brick wall goes up in your own mind, how this brick wall starts to form.
我可能变得有点冷酷了。我不知道，因为现在很多时候，当人们开始说那些博取同情的煽情话时，你就知道接下来会发生什么。这让你在心里筑起一道砖墙，这道砖墙开始形成。
Well, today on our program, windfalls and the power of money for good and bad over our own lives. Act One, Reservations. A story of an entire community that is turning its back on a fortune, and why that might not last. Act Two, But Baby It's Cold Outside. Writer Dan Savage, and how a windfall check he got in the mail is hurting his family life. Act Three, Money is Good. How one woman learned to stop worrying and start spending, spending, spending. Act Four, Pot of Gold. Scott Carrier tells the story of someone's life that improved with a huge insurance settlement even though the money never arrived. Stay with us.
好的，今天我们的节目主题是横财，以及金钱对我们生活的利与弊。第一幕，保留。一个社区背弃了一笔财富的故事，以及为什么这种情况可能不会持久。第二幕，宝贝，外面很冷。作家丹·萨维奇讲述了他收到的一张横财支票是如何伤害他家庭生活的。第三幕，金钱是好的。一位女性如何学会停止担忧并开始消费、消费、再消费。第四幕，金罐。斯科特·卡里尔讲述了一个人的生活如何因巨额保险赔偿而改善，尽管那笔钱从未真正到手。请继续收听。
Act One, Reservations. Nine years ago, a Native American tribe in Minnesota, the Mille Lacs Band of Ojibwe, built a casino. The reservation had been poor for a century. Soon they were the second biggest tourist attraction in the state, second only to the Mall of America. Soon they had hundreds of millions of dollars. And it's unclear what to do with all that cash. Alix Spiegel visited.
第一幕，保留。九年前，明尼苏达州的一个美洲原住民部落，奥吉布瓦族米拉湖分部，建了一家赌场。这个保留地已经贫穷了一个世纪。很快，他们就成了该州仅次于美国购物中心的第二大旅游景点。很快，他们就拥有了数亿美元。但如何处理这些现金尚不清楚。阿里克斯·斯皮格尔去进行了采访。
It's 8 o'clock on a Monday morning, and there are 1,000 people on the floor of the Grand Casino. 1,000 people have showered, brushed their hair and teeth, put on clothing, and traveled-- some of them significant distances-- to the Grand, where they're now pouring money into slot machines with an enthusiasm I don't usually associate with 8:00  AM Monday morning. I've been told a number of times by the people running the Grand that I'm not supposed to interview casino patrons with my tape machine. So I change a five and walk around with a bucket full of nickels, trying to look friendly.
那是周一早上8点，大赌场里已经有1000人了。这1000人洗了澡，梳了头，刷了牙，穿好衣服，长途跋涉来到这里，正热情高涨地把钱塞进老虎机，这种热情通常不会出现在周一早上的8点钟。赌场的工作人员多次告诫我不准用录音机采访赌客。所以我换了五块钱，提着一桶镍币走来走去，尽量让自己看起来友好一些。
I sit down next to a gray-haired man at a quarter slot and get as far as hello before he tells me to go away, I'm gambling, which I do. I walk a couple aisles over and take a seat next to a woman with two small pictures of her grandchildren propped up on the deck of her slot machine. Her name is Donna. She's 67 and travels every Monday from her home an hour way to gamble at the Grand. She plays from 8:00 in the morning until 2:00 in the afternoon and then returns home to work at her job as a bartender for the legion club.
我在一个玩25美分老虎机的灰发男人旁边坐下，还没来得及说“你好”，他就让我走开，说他在赌博。我只好走开，又走到几个走道外，坐在一个女人旁边，她的老虎机台上摆着两张孙辈的照片。她叫唐娜，67岁，每周一从一小时车程外的家里赶来大赌场赌博。她从早上8点一直玩到下午2点，然后回家去军团俱乐部做酒保的工作。
A couple times a month, she'll come to the casino with her husband, the farmer. And even though she's 67 and he's 74, they'll stay up all night gambling. On special occasions, like their birthday, they'll rent a room at the hotel next door. She tells me that the casino relaxes her. She says she saw on TV that they pump special oxygen through the air ducts in the ceiling, and she thinks this might have something to do with it.
每个月有几次，她会和身为农民的丈夫一起来赌场。尽管她67岁，他74岁，他们会彻夜赌博。在生日等特殊场合，他们会租下隔壁酒店的房间。她告诉我，赌场让她放松。她说她在电视上看到，赌场通过天花板的风道输送特殊的氧气，她认为这可能有点关系。
I'm here to do a story about the Grand Casino, about how the nickels pushed into slot machines by people like Donna have changed life on the Ojibwe reservation. So I try to interest Donna in a conversation about the people she's been feeding her paycheck to for the last two years. Donna isn't interested. She doesn't even remember the name of the tribe which owns the casino. She, like the other thousand people sitting on the casino floor, is just here looking for easy money.
我来这里是为了报道大赌场的故事，讲述像唐娜这样的人塞进老虎机的镍币是如何改变奥吉布瓦保留地生活的。所以我试图让唐娜对她过去两年一直在“喂养”的对象产生兴趣，但唐娜不感兴趣。她甚至记不住拥有这家赌场的部落名字。她和赌场里其他一千个人一样，只是来这里寻找快钱的。
Of course, the odds are stacked in the house's favor. So their pursuit of this windfall simply produces a windfall for someone else, the Ojibwe tribe. I try to talk about this with Donna as she works the buttons of her Wheel of Fortune slot. But she just nods, keeps her eyes glued to the spinning video screen in front of her, and lets me talk.
当然，赔率是对庄家有利的。因此，他们对横财的追求只会为别人——奥吉布瓦部落——创造横财。当唐娜操作她的“财富之轮”老虎机时，我试着和她谈论这一点，但她只是点点头，双眼紧盯着面前旋转的视频屏幕，让我一个人说。
OK, listen. This is brand new again. This road's never been here. So this is brand new here, a two-lane road and tar, nice and tar. These are some of our casino homes, built from casino profits. A lot of duplexes in this neighborhood. This is brand new neighborhood section.
好了，听着。这条路是全新的。以前这里没有路。所以这是全新的，双向柏油马路，非常漂亮。这些是我们的一些赌场住宅，用赌场利润建造的。这个街区有很多复式住宅。这是全新的社区区域。
Kenny Weyaus takes me on a tour of the Ojibwe reservation to show me what's new. A lot is new. We drive past new duplex homes on a new road with new curbing and new street lighting. We turn at the new water tower and circle the new spiritual center.
肯尼·韦亚斯带我游览奥吉布瓦保留地，向我展示新事物。很多东西都是新的。我们开车经过新路上的新复式住宅，路边有新的路缘石和新的路灯。我们在新的水塔处转弯，环绕着新的精神中心。
Kenny is a member of the Ojibwe tribe and a tour guide at the Native American museum. Our interview was set up by a PR guy who told me that Kenny knows as much about the Ojibwe as anyone in the tribe. He's 57 and has lived away from the reservation only twice, once after high school, when he moved south to train in the army, and again after his marriage, when the reservation economy was so poor he had to move to Minneapolis to find work.
肯尼是奥吉布瓦部落的成员，也是美洲原住民博物馆的导游。我们的采访是由一位公关人员安排的，他告诉我肯尼对奥吉布瓦的了解比部落里任何人都多。他57岁，只离开过保留地两次，一次是高中毕业后去南方参加军队训练，另一次是婚后因为保留地经济太差，不得不搬到明尼阿波利斯找工作。
All of this new dazzles Kenny. It means, among other things, that he won't have to move away from the reservation again. And as we pass each new building, he recites the date of its opening. The new museum, May 18, 1996. The new health clinic, December 12, 1992. We idle in the parking lot of the new lower school and admire the new playground, then drive down the street to yet another new cedar wood building.
所有这些新东西让肯尼眼花缭乱。这意味着，除其他事项外，他不必再离开保留地了。每经过一座新建筑，他都会念出它的开业日期。新博物馆，1996年5月18日。新健康诊所，1992年12月12日。我们在新小学停车场空转，欣赏着新的游乐场，然后开车去街上另一座新的雪松木建筑。
And right up here to our left is our high school. Yeah, that's a new one too. That came up just the same time as that lower school. And if you go inside, they got a new-- just like your church windows, they got that different colors. And they got those Indian designs up on the roof there, skylight. So it's beautiful inside, when you look up through that dome there.
左边就是我们的高中。是的，那也是新的。它和小学是同时建成的。如果你进去，你会看到一个新的——就像你们教堂的窗户一样，有不同的颜色。屋顶上有那种印第安图案，是天窗。当你透过那个圆顶向上看时，里面非常美。
As we circle to exit the school parking lot, I notice a freestanding, double-wide trailer tucked just behind the school's southern wing. It has colored paper pasted to its windows and some chipper looking signs.
当我们转弯准备离开学校停车场时，我注意到学校南翼后面藏着一辆独立的、双宽的拖车。窗户上贴着彩色纸，还有一些看起来很轻快的标语。
That's the old school, yeah. It used to be part of the old school.
那是旧学校，是的。它以前是旧学校的一部分。
It was just those two trailer homes?
以前就只是那两辆拖车屋吗？
Trailer homes like that, yeah. That's what they had for school, mobile homes like that connected. Back before '90, everybody lived in Minneapolis, or they were working in Minneapolis. And nobody wanted to come back here. If you brought somebody here, you didn't want to show somebody, oh, this is my home here, kind of run down. So that's kind of degrading, actually. You didn't want to tell anybody where you lived. [INAUDIBLE]. Since the casino came in, now everybody and everything's looking good. And today, even our employees are-- see, our minimum wage is $7 here. Before the Grand Casino came in, I think minimum wage was $3 to $4 an hour.
像那样的拖车屋，是的。那就是他们上学的地方，像那样连接起来的移动房屋。90年以前，每个人都住在明尼阿波利斯，或者在明尼阿波利斯工作。没人愿意回这里。如果你带人来这里，你不想让人看到，哦，这是我的家，有点破旧。这实际上挺丢人的。你不想告诉任何人你住在哪里。自从赌场建成后，现在每个人和每件事看起来都很好。而且今天，即使是我们的员工——你看，我们的最低工资是7美元。在大赌场进来之前，我想最低工资是每小时3到4美元。
Then we drive deeper into the reservation. We pass a dilapidated trailer and another, some HUD housing.
然后我们开车深入保留地。我们经过一辆破旧的拖车和另一辆，还有一些HUD（住房与城市发展部）的住房。
What's that?
那是什么？
That's a trailer house. A lot of people still got-- you still got so many here, people that live in old beat down trailer house, beat down homes and all of that. Not everybody here's got model homes.
那是拖车屋。很多人依然住在那儿——你在这里还是能看到很多人，住的是破旧的拖车屋，破房子之类的。不是每个人这里都有样板房。
Kenny doesn't say much about the broken-down trailers and public housing. But just across from the comfortable looking, middle-class homes the casino built, there are beat up trailers, trash-strewn yards, little kids walking barefoot around broken glass in a driveway, and the general feeling that things aren't going so well. The Niagara of money pouring into slot machines across the street clearly isn't reaching everyone. And this, in a funny way, is the choice of the tribal government, which takes a moment to explain.
肯尼没多说什么关于破旧拖车和公共住房的事。但在赌场建造的舒适的中产阶级住宅对面，就是那些破旧的拖车、到处是垃圾的院子、在车道碎玻璃上赤脚走着的小孩，给人一种一切并不顺利的普遍感觉。那条像尼亚加拉瀑布一样涌入对面老虎机的金钱显然并没有惠及所有人。有趣的是，这是部落政府的选择，政府花了一点时间来解释。
Of the 545 Native American tribes in the US, about 226 have gambling casinos. But most of these operations are too far away from a concentrated population to make any real money. Only a few, around 5%, generate significant profits. The Ojibwe are one of these tribes. So are the Mashantucket Pequot in Connecticut and the Ojibwe's neighbors, the Shakopee tribe, who have a casino just south of Minneapolis at Prior Lake.
在美国的545个美洲原住民部落中，约有226个经营着赌场。但这些业务大多数离人口稠密的地区太远，无法赚到真正的钱。只有少数，大约5%，能产生可观的利润。奥吉布瓦就是其中之一。康涅狄格州的马山图基特佩科特部落和奥吉布瓦的邻居沙科皮部落也是如此，他们在明尼阿波利斯南部的普里尔湖有一个赌场。
But the Pequot and the Shakopee are doing something very different with their windfalls. They're distributing the profits to their members on a per capita basis, which means that each month, every tribal member gets a check in the mail for their fair share of annual casino profits. The tribes don't publicize how large these checks are. Published accounts, which the Shakopee won't confirm, say that each Shakopee member gets $40,000 to $50,000 a month, which is a lot of money. And I should say here, that the Ojibwe tribe could never offer their members a payment of that size. Although it'd still be a lot by anyone's standards, conservative estimates are about $10,000 per year for every man, woman, and child in the tribe.
但佩科特和沙科皮对他们的横财处理方式非常不同。他们按人头向成员分配利润，这意味着每个月，每个部落成员都会收到一张支票，作为他们应得的年度赌场利润份额。部落不对外公布这些支票的具体金额。已发表的报道称，虽然沙科皮拒绝证实，但每个沙科皮成员每月能拿到4万到5万美元，这可是一大笔钱。我也应该说明，奥吉布瓦部落永远无法提供这种规模的支付。尽管这在任何人看来仍然是一笔巨款，但保守估计，部落里的每个男女老少每年大约能分到1万美元。
I ask Kenny if he'd prefer a system of per capita payments instead of a program of investing in buildings and social programs, as the Ojibwe have. And he doesn't pause at all. He doesn't want the money.
我问肯尼，他是否更喜欢人头分配制度，而不是像奥吉布瓦这样投入到建筑和社会项目中。他毫不犹豫。他不想要那笔钱。
I don't think it would be good around here. We go like that, we're going back in the old ways, I think, where you didn't even do nothing. That's how come we believe in that. It goes back into infrastructure instead of getting a monthly check every month or something like that.
我觉得这在这里不好。如果我们要那样做，我想我们又回到了老路，什么正事都不干。这就是为什么我们相信这一点。这些钱重新投入到基础设施中，而不是每个月领一张支票之类的。
Over the next couple days, I go out with a number of people from the tribe, nice, newly middle-class people set up for me by the PR man who's acting as my liaison. And whenever I ask them whether they'd want more money, say, in the form of per capita payments, their faces tighten, answers get general, and they all say no. They don't want per capita. They want everything to stay the way it is.
接下来的几天里，我走访了部落里的许多人，都是由我的公关联络人安排的、新晋中产阶级人士。每当我问他们是否想要更多钱，比如以人头支票的形式，他们的脸色就会紧绷，答案变得笼统，他们都说不。他们不想要人头分配。他们希望一切保持原样。
Like Kenny, they allude to the old ways. And I come to understand that the old ways is a euphemism for joblessness, alcoholism, and drug abuse. It's a difficult and embarrassing thing to talk about because it plays into ugly stereotypes about Native Americans and alcoholism. Because they're basically saying they think they could handle the money, but they worry that their family and neighbors can't. When I press one woman to articulate what she thinks will happen if they distribute the money, she tells me to turn off the tape recorder, then leans forward until I can see the pores in her nose. Easy money, she tells me, is dangerous. And this is where our interview ends.
像肯尼一样，他们提到了“老路”。我开始明白，“老路”是失业、酗酒和毒品滥用的委婉说法。这是一件既困难又尴尬的事情，因为这迎合了关于美洲原住民和酗酒的丑陋刻板印象。因为他们基本上是在说，他们认为自己能处理好这笔钱，但他们担心自己的家人和邻居做不到。当我逼问一位女性，让她说清楚如果分钱会发生什么时，她叫我关掉录音机，然后身体前倾，直到我能看到她鼻孔里的毛孔。快钱，她告诉我，是危险的。这就是我们采访结束的地方。
Early in the evening, I go driving on the reservation. In front of a row of HUD homes, I find two teenagers, Marcus and Wesley. As I drive up, they're running circles around an older man who's clearly inebriated. They're laughing, waving their hands in his face, taunting him as he tries to make his way down the street. I roll down my window and ask what they're up to, and the smaller one, Marcus, tells me they're terrorizing drunks.
傍晚时分，我开车在保留地巡视。在一排HUD住房前，我发现了两个十几岁的男孩，马库斯和韦斯利。我开车靠近时，他们正围着一个明显喝醉的老人跑圈。他们大笑着，在他脸上挥手，嘲弄着他，而他试图沿着街道走。我摇下车窗问他们在干什么，年纪较小的那个马库斯告诉我，他们在恐吓酒鬼。
So I get out of my rental, and we stand together on the street, watching the cars pass, talking about the casino, basically marking time until another victim stumbles by. Marcus and Wesley aren't impressed with what the casino money has accomplished for their community. They hold forth on the thesis that everyone on the reservation is still poor and still tired of not having anything and that everyone except the government wants per capita payments.
于是我下车，我们站在街上，看着汽车驶过，谈论着赌场，基本上是在打发时间，直到下一个受害者跌跌撞撞地走过来。马库斯和韦斯利对赌场为他们的社区带来的成就并不印象深刻。他们坚持认为保留地上的每个人仍然很穷，厌倦了一无所有，而且除了政府之外，每个人都想要人头分配。
As we talk, another old man staggers down the street towards us. He has two young girls with him. The older one holds his upper arm tightly and tries to steer him away from the curb. The younger ones skips behind and in front of him, almost under his feet.
当我们交谈时，另一个老人跌跌撞撞地向我们走来。他带着两个小女孩。年龄较大的那个紧紧抓着他的上臂，试图引导他避开路边。较小的那个在他脚边跑来跑去，差点被绊倒。
For instance, look at him. He needs per capitas.
比如，看他。他需要人头分配。
He's homeless. If he got capita payments, he could rent a house.
他是无家可归的。如果他有分配金，他就能租房子了。
Ask him what he thinks. Humpy, what do you think about the res?
问问他怎么想。亨皮，你觉得保留地怎么样？
Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。
Well done, [? Ardiro. ?]
干得好，[阿迪罗？]
You leave my uncle alone. Get away from him.
别管我叔叔。离他远点。
We wait some more. Every time a car goes by, Marcus waves at the person inside. I ask who it is, and he tells me it's his cousin.
我们又等了一会儿。每当有车经过，马库斯就向车里的人挥手。我问是谁，他告诉我那是他表亲。
Who is that?
那是谁？
That is my cousin, Joe.
那是我表亲，乔。
Two cousins pass. Three cousins pass. Four cousins pass.
两个表亲过去了。三个过去了。四个过去了。
Who's that guy?
那个人是谁？
Them are my cousins Ernie and Rodney.
那是我的表亲厄尼和罗德尼。
Pretty soon another figure staggers down the road in our direction. It's Wesley's cousin, Billy.
很快，另一个身影跌跌撞撞地朝我们走来。那是韦斯利的表亲，比利。
You could ask him what he thinks about the casino and stuff.
你可以问问他怎么看待赌场之类的。
Will you ask him?
你问问他好吗？
Would you like to answer some questions?
你想回答一些问题吗？
Shoot, about what?
说吧，关于什么？
The casino and how you think the res should give per caps.
赌场，以及你认为保留地是否应该发放分配金。
They know they owe us. Bottom line is [BLEEP].
他们知道他们欠我们的。底线是[消音]。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
What I mean by that is they should be giving us something back.
我的意思是他们应该回馈我们一些东西。
You don't think you're getting anything?
你不觉得你得到了什么吗？
No, we're not. Well, check us out man. There's like three families living in one house.
没有，我们没有。伙计，看看我们吧。一个房子里住了三家人。
Where?
哪里？
All over the place.
到处都是。
Like that house, they got, like, 11 kids and [BLEEP].
就像那个房子，他们有11个孩子和[消音]。
Billy used to work at the casino but got laid off. Now he lives with a family he says can't support him and gets by on welfare checks. Everyone agrees that about half the tribe wants per capitas. And it's people like Billy, the people who are worst off, who tend to want them the most.
比利曾经在赌场工作，但被解雇了。现在他住在一个他说养不起他的家庭里，靠福利支票过活。每个人都同意，大约一半的部落成员想要分配金。而像比利这样生活最困难的人，往往最想要分配金。
People think we got it made down here. We do not got it made. It's hard to live here. Ever since that casino got here, it's harder for us to live, because we're expecting to live but we're not. After a while, we have to start thinking about, where's all this money going that we got. That's what I want to know.
人们以为我们在这里过得很好。我们并没有过得好。住在这里很难。自从赌场建在这里，我们反而更难生活了，因为我们本以为能过上好日子，但却没有。过了一段时间，我们开始思考，我们得到的这些钱都去哪儿了。这就是我想知道的。
You know, this is a thankless job. It's--
你知道，这是一份吃力不讨好的工作。它是——
Marge Anderson is the chief of the Ojibwe tribe. She's a small woman who sits in a large office with all the props of the executive around her, a small golf green, a big mahogany desk, a mug with the appropriate observation about where the buck stops, and pictures. Marge with Bill Clinton, Marge with Bruce Springsteen, Marge smiling with Johnny Cash.
玛吉·安德森是奥吉布瓦部落的首领。她是一位矮小的女性，坐在宽敞的办公室里，周围摆满了行政人员的道具：一个小高尔夫果岭、一张大红木桌子、一个写着关于权责发生地观察的马克杯，还有照片。玛吉和比尔·克林顿的照片，玛吉和布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的照片，玛吉和约翰尼·卡什微笑着的照片。
Marge has been tribal chief since '91, when the casino opened. She's the person who has presided over the tribe's economic boom. The person who built the roads and built the schools, and through sheer force of will, made the reservation a much better place than it was 10 years ago. She's also the main opponent of distributing profits through per capita payments, though it's such a sensitive issue right now that when I ask her about it, she tells me to turn off my tape recorder.
玛吉自91年赌场开业以来一直是部落首领。她是见证了部落经济繁荣的人。是她修了路，建了学校，并凭借纯粹的意志力，使保留地变得比10年前好得多。她也是反对通过人头支付分配利润的主要对手，尽管这是一个非常敏感的话题，以至于当我问她时，她让我关掉录音机。
Finally, I get her to say this on tape--
最终，我让她在录音中说了这些——
You know. I see what's happening in these other communities, where you have alcohol problems, you have drug problems, you have just dependency problems where I think it's self-defeating.
你知道。我看到了其他社区正在发生的事情，那里有酒精问题、毒品问题，还有单纯的依赖问题，我认为这是自取灭亡。
Marge knows that many people in the tribe want per caps. She even knows this may cost her her job. In the last election, the tribe voted in a new secretary treasurer who ran on a per capita platform, promising to give more casino money directly to tribal members. And Marge is worried that he might disrupt the work she's accomplished. And she's getting tired. She sighs and tells me that her job takes too much time. She's frequently away on weekends. She says she's afraid that her grandchildren won't know her.
玛吉知道部落里许多人想要分配金。她甚至知道这可能会让她丢掉工作。在上次选举中，部落选出了一位新的财务秘书，他主张人头分配，承诺将更多的赌场资金直接发给部落成员。玛吉担心他可能会破坏她取得的成果。她感到累了。她叹了口气告诉我，她的工作太花时间了。她经常在周末外出。她说她担心自己的孙辈将来不认识她。
In addition to the problem of trying to convince a group of people who are poor that they should not vote themselves more money, she's now fending off her white neighbors who are threatening to take away the casino and the casino profits entirely.
除了试图说服一群穷人不要投票给自己更多钱的难题外，她现在还要抵御威胁要夺走赌场和全部利润的白人邻居。
If history repeats itself, then one of these days, the casino's going to be gone. Some way, somehow, somebody's going to find a way to take it away from us again.
如果历史重演，那么总有一天，赌场会消失。以某种方式，不知怎的，总有人会找到办法再次夺走它。
You think that?
你这么认为？
I really believe that, because of the way things are going right now. Now we have a compact with the State of Minnesota that allows us to do this. And the compact is perpetual. There's no ending date on it. And now you have those that want to renegotiate. Let's open up that compact. And you know what? What they want to open up the contract so they can break it again.
我真的这么认为，因为现在事情发展的方向。我们现在与明尼苏达州有一个契约，允许我们这样做。这个契约是永久的。没有终止日期。现在有人想重新谈判。让我们打开那个契约。你知道吗？他们想打开合同是为了再次撕毁它。
And one of the things that these negotiators said was, had we known these tribes were going to be that successful, we would never have signed a compact with them. So what does that say? They wanted us to fail again? I know, it is frustrating. And it just-- I sit here and sometimes I just say, what the heck is the use?
其中一位谈判代表说，如果我们知道这些部落会如此成功，我们绝不会和他们签署契约。那说明什么？他们想让我们再次失败？我知道，这很令人沮丧。有时我坐在这里，我就想，到底有什么意义呢？
In part, it's this possibility, that the casino will be taken away, that gives such urgency to Marge's opposition to per capita payments. She feels the tribe must use every scrap of money that they have to diversify their economy, create an economy that is not dependent on the casino. So she's buying pizza franchises and investing in bottled water, and generally pouring the tribe's money into industries which aren't subject to the whims of state legislators. She feels there is a window here, just a brief sliver of time, before the jealousy of their white neighbors or the innate attraction of easy money overwhelms them.
在某种程度上，正是这种赌场可能被夺走的可能性，才使得玛吉对分配金的反对变得如此迫切。她觉得部落必须利用每一分钱来使经济多样化，创造一个不依赖赌场的经济。所以她收购比萨连锁店，投资瓶装水，通常将部落的钱投入到不受州立法者反复无常影响的行业中。她觉得这里有一个窗口期，只有短暂的一点时间，在白人邻居的嫉妒或快钱的内在吸引力压倒他们之前。
This is what the petition says. It says, we, the band membership, call for a referendum vote for 80-20 or more per capita payment for adult band members in fiscal 1999 and beyond.
这就是请愿书的内容。它说，我们，成员，呼吁进行公投，要求在1999财年及以后，为成年成员提供80%或更多的分配金。
When I met Mishkoob, he had just come back from collecting signatures. He had a clipboard with Mille Lacans for Progress written on top and five new names penciled on the petition. The PR man at the casino warned me that Mishkoob was a zealot and a radical. And when I sit down at his kitchen table, there are charts and graphs everywhere, heaped in piles on the floors, scattered over the desk by the window. And then, suspended from a hook on the wall by the desk, an unsteady looking bar chart which tracks the growth of the Ojibwe government's budget. Mishkoob pounds the kitchen table and makes his argument.
当我见到米什库布时，他刚收集完签名回来。他拿着一个文件夹，上面写着“为进步的米拉湖人”，上面还有五个刚写上去的新名字。赌场的公关人员警告我，米什库布是个狂热分子和激进分子。当我坐在他的厨房桌子旁时，到处都是图表和图形，地板上堆成堆，窗边的桌子上散落着。然后，墙上的挂钩上悬挂着一张看起来不太稳定的柱状图，追踪着奥吉布瓦政府预算的增长。米什库布重重地拍了拍厨房桌子，提出了他的论点。
Everybody else is getting the money but the average band member who owns all this. See, that's the thing that band members need to get through their thick skulls, is that this is all theirs. It's their casino. It's their hotel. For every poor Mille Lac person on the reservation now, there's probably no less than three non-Indians working, telling us what to do, where to go, how we're going to do it, what's the future, what's our plan, what store to buy, what bank to buy, what gas station to buy, how much dirt is needed. Everybody else is out there getting paid big bucks of our money because we're the poor clients.
除了拥有这一切的普通成员外，其他所有人都在拿钱。看，这就是成员们需要灌进他们榆木脑袋里的东西，这一切都是他们的。这是他们的赌场。这是他们的酒店。现在保留地上的每一个穷困的米拉湖人，背后可能有至少三个非印第安人在工作，告诉我们该做什么、去哪里、怎么做、未来是什么、计划是什么、买什么商店、买什么银行、买什么加油站、需要多少土。其他人都在花我们的钱拿高薪，因为我们是穷客户。
Mishkoob's heard the arguments against per capita. He's heard the rumors that other tribes who have tried the per capita system have had problems with boozing or lack of motivation, but dismisses the possibility that these problems will afflict the Ojibwe.
米什库布听过反对分配金的论点。他听过传闻说其他尝试过分配金制度的部落出现了酗酒或缺乏动力的问题，但他排除了这些问题会困扰奥吉布瓦的可能性。
I'd like to believe that Mille Lacs is going to be the exception to the rule. Now, like I keep saying, there's only 1,500 adults. Now, they're all not going to start taking drugs and start drinking. Most of them are responsible people. And given the opportunity, they will make the right choices.
我想相信米拉湖会成为例外。正如我一直说的，只有1500名成年人。他们不会都开始吸毒和酗酒。他们大多数是负责任的人。只要给予机会，他们会做出正确的选择。
That night, I run into Marcus, Wesley, and their friend Courtney at the casino, and we all pile into the rental and go cruising. It was supposed to be the first day of school for Marcus and Courtney, but Marcus hasn't enrolled yet, and Courtney got suspended for setting fires in the time out room. So no one in the car had anything to do in the morning but me.
那天晚上，我在赌场遇到了马库斯、韦斯利和他们的朋友考特尼，我们都挤进租来的车去兜风。这对马库斯和考特尼来说本应该是开学第一天，但马库斯还没注册，考特尼因为在冷静室里放火被停课了。所以车里除了我，没别的事可做。
We visit a friend of theirs, Rae Ann, but the boys are restless. They want to go riding. They want to turn donuts in the dirt road behind the casino. They want to go tail whipping down at Moon Lake. They want to do these things in the rental. Mostly though, they want me to buy them alcohol.
我们去看了他们的朋友瑞·安，但男孩们坐不住了。他们想去兜风。他们想在赌场后面的土路上玩转圈。他们想去月亮湖玩拖曳。他们想开着租来的车做这些事。不过主要是，他们想让我给他们买酒。
Let's go to the liquor store.
我们去酒铺吧。
And who is going to buy? I can't buy you liquor.
谁来买？我不能给你们买酒。
Why not? Everybody else does.
为什么不行？别人都买。
I offer McDonald's instead, my treat. There's general approval and we leave Rae Ann and drive north for cheeseburgers.
我提议请客吃麦当劳。大家一致同意，于是我们留下瑞·安，开车向北去吃芝士汉堡。
In the car, we talk mostly girls, automobiles, and the supernatural. Wesley tells me that ghosts walk the shoulders of the roads at night. He says they're all around the woods. In the western part of the reservation, an area called The Point is filled with them at night. Finally, we finish our McDonald's run and drive down to a park by the lake to eat. The park is empty, just a picnic table, some scattered trash, and us.
车里，我们谈论的大多是女孩、汽车和超自然现象。韦斯利告诉我，晚上有鬼魂走在路肩上。他说树林里到处都是。在保留地西部，一个叫“尖点”的地方晚上全是这些东西。最后，我们吃完了麦当劳，开车到湖边的公园吃。公园空无一人，只有一个野餐桌，一些散落的垃圾，还有我们。
We sit together in the car, eating sweet and salty food. And when we finish, I tell them about my conversation with Marge, about how she wants to save the casino money. So that if the white people take the casino away, there will still be industry on the res. Her fear that people will take the money and blow it on drink and drugs. Marcus and Wesley are quiet, but Courtney pipes up.
我们坐在车里，吃着甜甜咸咸的食物。吃完后，我告诉他们我和玛吉的谈话，关于她想如何节省赌场的钱。这样如果白人夺走了赌场，保留地上仍然有产业。她担心人们会拿着钱挥霍在酒和毒品上。马库斯和韦斯利沉默了，但考特尼开口了。
I know I'd be spending all my money on liquor.
我知道我会把所有的钱都花在酒上。
Do you think so?
你真的这么认为吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So do you think that they're doing the right thing?
那你觉得他们做得对吗？
Probably, yeah.
大概吧，是的。
Who would you vote for, somebody who said that they would give you per capita or somebody who said that they wouldn't?
你会投给谁，一个说会给你分配金的人，还是一个说不会给的人？
Someone who said they would, I'd vote for them.
我会投给说会给的人。
Even though you think that if you did get the money, you probably wouldn't get a job?
即使你认为如果真的得到了钱，你可能就不会去工作了？
Yep.
是的。
And even though you said that you also think that they're doing the right thing?
即使你说你也认为他们做得对？
Yeah.
是的。
That's kind of--
那有点——
Confusing.
令人困惑。
--that is kind of confusing.
——那确实有点令人困惑。
Yeah.
是的。
There's a wall of winners at the Grand Casino. It's covered ceiling to ground with framed photographs of jackpot winners. Most of them look frenzied with happiness. They hold fans of money over open mouths, balance oversized checks on their hips. And in the middle of the wall of photos, there's a picture frame, the same size and shape as the others, with a mirrored surface, where the winner's picture would be, and the words, this could be you, written in block lettering. It's a hard message to resist.
大赌场有一面胜者墙。从天花板到地面贴满了头奖得主的装裱照片。他们大多数看起来幸福得近乎疯狂。他们手里拿着扇形的钞票放在张开的嘴边，把超大支票扛在胯部。在照片墙中间，有一个相框，大小和形状与其他人一样，表面是镜面，本该是赢家的照片，上面写着“这可能就是你”，是用黑体字写的。这是一个很难抗拒的信息。
[MUSIC - "AMERICA" BY LITTLE JACK MELODY AND HIS YOUNG TURKS]
[音乐 - 小杰克·梅洛迪和他的年轻土耳其人的《美国》]
Act Two, But Baby It's Cold Outside. Now this story of how a sudden influx of money affected one otherwise happy home, that of writer Dan Savage in Seattle. A warning to some listeners, Dan mentions the fact that he's a homosexual in the upcoming story.
第二幕，宝贝，外面很冷。现在这个故事讲述了金钱的突然涌入如何影响了一个原本幸福的家庭，西雅图作家丹·萨维奇的家庭。给听众的一个警告，丹在接下来的故事中提到了他是同性恋的事实。
The check came in the mail. I didn't even get to see it, never got to hold it in my hand and marvel at the string of zeroes that came before the decimal point. My boyfriend Terry deposited the check as if it were any old check that came in the mail to our house. Our money goes straight into our joint checking account, so I never got to see our check. But this wasn't like any of our other checks. This was the single largest check ever made out in my name that didn't arrive in a yellow envelope with Ed McMahon's picture on it.
支票寄到了家里。我甚至没看到它，从来没能把它拿在手里，感叹小数点前那一串零。我的男友泰瑞像对待寄到我们家的任何旧支票一样存了它。我们的钱直接进入共同支票账户，所以我从没见过我们的支票。但这和我们其他的支票都不一样。这是我名下开出的金额最大的一张支票，不是那种带着艾德·麦克马洪照片的黄色信封里寄来的。
I write a sex advice column. And a book publisher got this crazy idea that they might make money for themselves by publishing a collection of my old columns. On the expectation that they would make money, the publisher gave me some money. I rewrote my old columns, and shortly before the book came out, they sent me a check.
我写一个性建议专栏。一家图书出版商想出了一个疯狂的主意，他们可以通过出版我旧专栏的合集来为自己赚钱。出于他们会赚钱的预期，出版商给了我一笔钱。我重写了旧专栏，在书出版前不久，他们寄给我一张支票。
I don't have it in me to tell you how much this check was for. I couldn't stand to hear from people that I got paid too much or too little. And it's hard for me to talk about money anyway. Money was scarce when I was a kid. My parents had four kids in Catholic schools and braces, and paying for it all on a Chicago cop's salary was not easy. Conversations about money were unpleasant. My family avoided talking about money just like we avoided talking about how drunk Grandma always seemed to be.
我没法告诉你这张支票是多少钱。我无法忍受听到别人说我拿得太多或太少。无论如何，谈论金钱对我来说很难。我小时候钱很紧。父母要供四个孩子上天主教学校和戴牙套，靠一个芝加哥警察的薪水负担这一切并不容易。关于钱的对话是不愉快的。我的家人避免谈论金钱，就像我们避免谈论外婆看起来总是喝得有多醉一样。
So I can't bring myself to tell you how much this windfall came to. But I will say this, it was in the low to high-mid five figures, OK? It was 10 times as much money as I made the year I turned 30. Enough money to make me feel so monumentally guilty, that after Terry told me the check came, I had to lie down in a dark room for the rest of the afternoon.
所以我无法让自己告诉你这笔横财到底是多少。但我会这么说，它是五位数的低端到中高端，好吗？这是我30岁那年赚的钱的10倍。这笔钱足以让我感到巨大的内疚，以至于泰瑞告诉我支票寄到后，我不得不在黑暗的房间里躺了一整个下午。
Before the money had a chance to settle into our checking account and get acquainted with what little bit of money was already there, my boyfriend Terry was making plans to spend it and spend all of it. Terry likes spending money, especially our money, which I like to think of as my money, since I earn it. But I have to push these thoughts out of my head and let Terry regard my money as his. That's the deal we made when we decided to adopt.
在钱有机会存入我们的支票账户并与里面已有的那点钱相识之前，我的男友泰瑞就在计划花掉它，而且要全部花光。泰瑞喜欢花钱，特别是我们的钱，我喜欢称之为我的钱，因为是我赚的。但我必须把这些想法赶出脑海，让泰瑞把我的钱当成他的。那是我们决定领养时达成的协议。
Terry quit working to stay at home with the baby for a couple of years. We're having a family the old-fashioned way. Our relationship, with the exception of the two penises thing, is very traditional. Terry stays at home and takes care of the baby. I go out in the world and make the money. In other words, a stay-at-home fag, a go-to-work fag, and one little baby's sexual orientation to be determined at a later date. As Terry sees it, it's my job to make money, and his job to spend it.
泰瑞辞职在家带孩子已经有一两年了。我们在以传统方式组建家庭。除了有两个阴茎这件事之外，我们的关系非常传统。泰瑞待在家里照顾孩子。我走到外面赚钱。换句话说，一个全职同性恋爸爸，一个外出工作的同性恋爸爸，还有一个性取向待定的小宝宝。在泰瑞看来，赚钱是我的工作，花钱是他的工作。
I, however, cannot spend money. When I was growing up, spending money was just as painful as talking about money. More. My mom would drive all four of us out to the Sears at Irving and Western in Chicago at the beginning of the school year. While my brothers and sister ran around oblivious to what was actually going on, sensitive little faggy me would see the tortured look on my mother's face as she realized she couldn't afford back-to-school clothes for all of us. Then I'd watch her pull out her Sears credit card, pray it wasn't maxed out, and hand it to the sales clerk.
然而，我无法花钱。在我成长过程中，花钱和谈论钱一样痛苦。甚至更痛苦。开学前夕，妈妈会开车带我们四个去芝加哥欧文和西部大街的西尔斯。当我兄弟姐妹跑来跑去，不知道实际发生了什么时，敏感的我看着妈妈意识到她负担不起我们要用的文具用品时脸上痛苦的表情。然后我会看着她掏出西尔斯信用卡，祈祷它没刷爆，然后把它递给店员。
On two occasions when it was just mom and me, her Sears card was maxed out. Seeing my mom turn red and say no when the clerk asked if she could pay cash was heartbreaking. To this day, I hate to shop. I don't do malls or department stores or boutiques or even catalogs. High-tech options are no better. I get the same sick feeling surfing into the virtual Gap that I get walking into an actual Gap.
有两次只有我和妈妈的时候，她的西尔斯卡刷爆了。看着妈妈脸涨得通红，在店员问她是否可以用现金支付时说“不”，真是令人心碎。直到今天，我讨厌购物。我不去商场、百货公司、精品店，甚至不看邮购目录。高科技的选择也没好到哪去。上网浏览虚拟的Gap和走进真正的Gap，我感到同样的恶心。
But Terry loves to shop. Traditional enough to begin with, our relationship is never quite so comically traditional as it is when we fight about money. Or I should say, when we fight about how Terry spends money, my money. After the baby came and Terry stopped working, I thought I'd managed to pound some sense into his head. We couldn't live paycheck to paycheck now that we had a baby. We needed money in the bank in case the baby got leukemia or something, or if I did. Terry saw the logic, and we agreed we would both buy less and save more.
但泰瑞喜欢购物。我们的关系起初足够传统，但在我们为了钱争吵时，从来没有像现在这样滑稽地传统。或者我应该说，当我们为了泰瑞如何花钱——我的钱——而争吵时。孩子出生后，泰瑞不再工作，我以为我设法把一些理智灌进了他的脑袋。现在有了孩子，我们不能再过那种月光族的生活。我们需要在银行存钱，以防孩子得了白血病什么的，或者我得了。泰瑞看到了逻辑，我们同意双方都要少买多存。
That's not how it worked out. Buying less was easy enough for me, as I never bought much to begin with. But spending money, including money he did not have, was always Terry's hobby. And pretty soon Terry was taking the baby for walks through Old Navy and Nordstrom's and Barnes and Noble. When the baby was asleep at home, Terry was getting online and buying CDs.
结果并不是那样。少买对我来说很容易，因为我本来买得就不多。但花钱，包括花他没有的钱，一直是泰瑞的爱好。很快，泰瑞就开始带着孩子逛海军老店、诺德斯特龙和巴诺书店。当孩子在家睡觉时，泰瑞就上网买CD。
Now, this is where it gets comic, sitcom-ic. Think Lucy and Ricky. Since he knows it makes me angry when he spends money on stuff we really don't need, clothes, shoes, music, money we might need if the baby or I get leukemia or something, my boyfriend always hides the things he buys. But since we live in a very small house, there aren't many places to hide things. So I go into a closet looking for my shoes or a coat, and I find a shopping bag hidden behind our old clothes full of brand new clothes, or a box of new CDs.
现在，这就是它变得滑稽、情景喜剧化的地方。想想露西和里奇。既然他知道把钱花在我们不需要的东西上——衣服、鞋子、音乐——我们可能需要预防白血病或其他事情的钱——会让我生气，我的男友总是藏起他买的东西。但由于我们住的房子很小，没什么地方可藏东西。所以我进壁橱找鞋子或外套时，就会发现藏在我们旧衣服后面装满新衣服的购物袋，或者一盒新CD。
A la Ricky Ricardo, I storm into the living room and ask-- and I apologize in advance for my lousy, mock Cuban accent-- honey, what is this, holding up the bag. A  la Lucy Ricardo, Terry denies ever having seen the bag before. Well, how did this get into our closet, then, I ask. I don't know, pouts Terry. Oh, Lucy, I exclaim. Whaa, cries Terry.
像里奇·里卡多一样，我冲进客厅问——我提前为我那糟糕的、模仿古巴口音道歉——“甜心，这是什么？”举起袋子。像露西·里卡多一样，泰瑞否认以前见过这个袋子。“那么这东西是怎么进我们壁橱的？”我问。“我不知道，”泰瑞噘着嘴说。“噢，露西，”我感叹道。“哇，”泰瑞哭道。
These were the dynamics at play when the big check arrived, the one with all those zeroes. Our windfall took a bad situation and made it much, much worse. In my mind, what had been a little gun in Terry's hand, our checking account, became a nuclear weapon. If it had been up to me, we wouldn't have deposited that check. After all, if we didn't cash it, it couldn't hurt us or change anything.
这些就是那张大支票寄到时在起作用的动态，带着那么多零的那张。我们的横财把一个糟糕的局面变得更糟、更糟了。在我看来，原本泰瑞手里的一把小枪——我们的支票账户——变成了一个核武器。如果由我决定，我们根本就不会存那张支票。毕竟，如果我们不兑现它，它就无法伤害我们或改变任何事情。
So a few days after Terry deposited our check, I did something patriarchal, very Father Knows Best. Something unlike anything I'd ever done before. Out of our joint checking account, I wrote myself a check for the full amount of my advance and deposited that check in an account only I have access to, my old savings account. I was afraid that if I left our money in our joint checking account, our windfall would disappear one afternoon while I was at work. Oh yeah, I knew Terry could spend the entire amount, the whole low to high-mid five figures, at one go.
所以在泰瑞存入我们支票的几天后，我做了一件家长式、非常“父亲最懂”的事情。做了一件我从未做过的事。从我们的共同支票账户里，我写了一张全额支票给自己，并把支票存入只有我能使用的账户，我以前的储蓄账户。我害怕如果我把钱留在我们的共同支票账户里，我们的横财有一天下午我在工作时就会消失。噢是的，我知道泰瑞可以一次就把全部金额，那五位数的低端到中高端，全部花掉。
I moved the money out of our checking account after Terry made the mistake of telling me what he wanted to buy with it, a new car. I think that's a bad idea for several reasons. First, it appears the planet is about to fall into a worldwide economic recession-cum-depression. And people tend to need less sex advice in a recession. And I'm concerned that the sex advice business, like liposuction and website design, might dry up if everyone is standing in bread lines or jumping out windows. I'd rather have the money in the bank.
泰瑞犯了一个错误，告诉我他想用这些钱买一辆新车，我就把钱从我们的支票账户里转走了。我认为这是个坏主意，原因有几个。首先，看来地球正处于全球经济衰退加萧条的边缘。而人们在衰退中对性建议的需求往往会减少。我担心性建议业务，像吸脂和网站设计一样，如果每个人都站在面包队列里或从窗户跳下，可能会枯竭。我宁愿把钱存在银行。
Secondly, I don't want a car. I'm 34. I've never owned a car. I don't know how to drive. I suggested to Terry that we buy a beat-up old car, something priced in the low four figures or high three. But he insisted we needed a new car, not for us, but for the baby. We need a safe car, a Volvo or something. He promises no more shopping once we've got it. And if me or the baby does come down with leukemia, Terry pointed out, he'll need a new car to get us back and forth to our chemotherapy appointments. And he swears that if we buy a car, we'll eat nothing but macaroni and cheese and wear only rags for the rest of our lives. At war with my inner voices, I agree to spend our money to buy us a car that I can't drive.
其次，我不想要车。我34岁了。我从来没拥有过车。我不知道怎么开车。我建议泰瑞买一辆破旧的旧车，价格在四位数的低端或三位数的高端。但他坚持认为我们需要一辆新车，不是为我们，而是为孩子。我们需要一辆安全的车，沃尔沃之类的。他保证一旦有了车就不再购物。如果我和孩子得了白血病，泰瑞指出，他将需要一辆新车带我们往返化疗预约。他发誓如果我们买车，我们余生将只吃通心粉和奶酪，只穿破布。在与内心的声音斗争后，我同意花钱买一辆我不会开的车。
Terry has started shopping with a vengeance. He's reading books on smart car buying, visiting all the internet sites, getting advice from people with experience buying cars. While Terry shops, I worry. Early in our relationship, when we first moved in with each other, one of my first official acts as Terry's boyfriend was to pay off his low to mid-low four figure credit card debt. He was supposed to pay me back a certain amount every month, but after three months, I told him to stop. We'd already merged our checking accounts, so the check he was writing me every month came out of our checking account. And I would put the money back into our checking account, and Terry would spend it. It was all a little silly, so I told him to stop, and I joked about having bought myself a boyfriend.
泰瑞开始疯狂购物。他正在阅读关于明智购车的书籍，访问所有互联网网站，获取有购车经验的人的建议。泰瑞购物时，我很担心。在我们的关系初期，我们刚搬到一起住时，我作为泰瑞男友的第一个正式行动就是偿还了他四位数的低端到中低端的信用卡债务。他本应每个月还我一笔钱，但三个月后，我告诉他停止了。我们已经合并了支票账户，所以他每个月写给我的支票是从我们的共同账户里出的。我会把钱放回共同账户，泰瑞就会把它花掉。这一切有点傻，所以我告诉他停止了，并开玩笑说自己买了一个男友。
As time went on and I started making enough money that we could contemplate Terry not working, I stopped joking about buying a boyfriend, because sometimes I worry that's exactly what I've done. Is Terry just another windfall? I love Terry, but does Terry love me? Or does he love not having to worry, for the time being at least, about supporting himself? Or if that's why he loves me, is that OK? There are lots of reasons people love their partners. And the notion that the only valid one is sexual passion is pretty limiting. Maybe part of the reason Terry loves me is because checks come in the mail. And maybe that is OK.
随着时间的推移，我开始赚到足够的钱，我们可以考虑泰瑞不用工作，我不再开玩笑说买男友了，因为有时我担心那正是我的所作所为。泰瑞只是另一笔横财吗？我爱泰瑞，但泰瑞爱我吗？或者他爱的是不用担心养活自己，至少暂时不用？或者如果那是他爱我的原因，那没关系吗？人们爱他们的伴侣有很多原因。认为唯一的有效原因是性激情的想法太受限了。也许泰瑞爱我的一部分原因是因为信箱里有支票。也许那没关系。
More than any other force in a relationship, more even than sex-- and I say this to you as a sex columnist-- money always seems to push people to the extremes of their characters. Money turns ordinary people into caricatures of themselves. Money was a large part of what destroyed my parent's marriage. And now I find myself worrying that money concerns, who makes it, how it's spent, the pressure I'm under to make more, the pressure Terry's under to spend less, will do long-term harm to my relationship with Terry. Because the problem with money is that money problems are never just about money. They're about who you are. And right now in our house, there are only two options. You're either Lucy or you're Ricky.
比起关系中的任何其他力量，甚至比起性——我是作为性专栏作家对你这么说的——金钱似乎总是把人们推向他们性格的极端。金钱把普通人变成了他们自己的漫画形象。金钱是我父母婚姻破裂的重要部分。现在我发现自己担心金钱问题——谁赚钱，怎么花钱，我赚更多钱的压力，泰瑞少花钱的压力——会对我和泰瑞的关系造成长期伤害。因为金钱的问题在于，金钱问题从来不仅仅是钱的问题。它们是关于你是谁的问题。目前在我们家里，只有两个选择。你要么是露西，要么是里奇。
If Dan Savage has offended you in some way over the years, if you hate his sex advice column, if you want for some reason to destroy his personal life, you can do it by buying his new book, Savage Love: Straight Answers from America's Most Popular Sex Columnist. Coming up, money is good not bad, even money you don't have. Two case studies. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
如果丹·萨维奇多年来以某种方式冒犯了你，如果你讨厌他的性建议专栏，如果你出于某种原因想摧毁他的个人生活，你可以通过买他的新书《萨维奇的爱：来自美国最受欢迎性专栏作家的直接回答》来做到。接下来，金钱是好的不是坏的，甚至是那些你没有的钱。两个案例研究。那是从国际公共电台节目继续开始的一分钟。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Windfall. What happens to you when you make the big score, for better and for worse. And up until the point in this program, I'd have the moral of every story has been very-- how to say this-- it's been very public radio. That is, the lesson of every story has been money is scary. Money is bad. Money can lead to dangerous feelings and things and make people unhappy. And so as an antidote to that, in this half of our program, we bring you stories of money actually doing people some good.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你各种关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，横财。当你赚了大钱时会发生什么，无论是好是坏。在节目的这个点之前，我得说每个故事的寓意都非常——怎么说呢——非常有公共电台特色。也就是说，每个故事的教训都是金钱是可怕的。金钱是坏的。金钱会导致危险的感觉和事情，并使人们不快乐。所以作为对那一点的解毒剂，在节目的下半部分，我们带给你金钱实际上带给人们好处的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Money is Good. Picture, please, this couple. When Elizabeth was seven, her father sat her and her 10-year-old sister down at the kitchen table with a bunch of charts, a bar graph, showing what college tuition would cost by the time each of them hit 18, and how much of that Elizabeth and her sister would be expected to pay themselves, and how they should start earning and saving right away.
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，金钱是好的。请想象这对夫妻。伊丽莎白七岁时，她父亲让她和她10岁的姐姐坐在厨房桌子旁，拿出一堆图表、一张柱状图，显示她们每个人到18岁时大学学费会花多少钱，她们每个人预计自己要付多少，她们应该如何立即开始赚钱和储蓄。
And we took this in very, very seriously. And then it just sort of started this-- I just remember going to school the next day and sitting next to my friend Sandy Thornberg and telling him about it. And saying to him-- I was seven years old-- and I said to him, man, how am I ever going to raise that kind of cash? I'm only seven. What can I possibly do?
我们非常非常认真地接受了这一点。然后它就像是开始了这种——我记得第二天去学校，坐在我的朋友桑迪·索恩伯格旁边告诉他。我告诉他——我七岁——我对他说，伙计，我怎么可能筹到那种现金？我才七岁。我能做什么？
Meanwhile, four states away, same year, 1978, when Mike was 11, his mom woke up him, his brothers, and his sister in the middle of the night, dragged them down to their dining table where their dad was sitting with some paper lunch bags.
与此同时，四个州之外，同一年，1978年，迈克11岁时，妈妈在半夜叫醒了他和他的兄弟姐妹，把他们拖到他们的餐桌旁，爸爸坐在那里，拿着几个纸午餐袋。
He kind of drew in a big breath and looked into each of our faces, and reached over and grabbed these paper bags, and dumped about $20,000 in $20 bills out onto the table.
他深吸了一口气，看着我们每个人的脸，伸手抓起这些纸袋，把大约两万美元的20元钞票倒在桌子上。
His dad had been to the races, won the trifecta. But he did not put it away for the kid's college or invest it or pay off the mortgage or save anything.
他爸爸去赛马赢了三重彩。但他没有把它存起来作为孩子的大学学费，也没有投资、还抵押贷款或存钱。
We re-carpeted the house. We bought VCRs. We bought waterbeds for everybody.
我们重新铺了房子的地毯。我们买了录像机。我们给每个人买了水床。
Waterbeds for everybody is a phrase you almost never hear. Waterbeds for everybody.
“给每个人买水床”是一个你几乎永远听不到的短语。给每个人买水床。
Not enough. Waterbeds for all my friends.
还不够。给我所有的朋友买水床。
Two decades later, this man meets this woman. Situation, he'd just lost his job. It was rough. Needed to drink. Her situation, she had a job tending bar. And the money thing came up pretty fast.
二十年后，这个男人遇到了这个女人。情况是，他刚丢了工作。很难。需要喝酒。她的情况，她在酒吧做酒保。金钱问题很快就出现了。
Our very first conversation about money, in fact, was the first night I met Liz in the bar. And my friends and I had gone in to drink. And we drank all night. We drank until 5:00 or 6:00 or 7:00 in the morning. And when we were out of money, there was nothing left but lint in our pockets. Liz said, well, listen, why don't I close down the bar and I'll take you all out to breakfast. And she did.
事实上，我们关于金钱的第一次对话就是我第一晚在酒吧遇到莉兹的时候。我和我的朋友进去喝酒。我们喝了一整晚。我们一直喝到凌晨5点、6点或7点。当我们没钱的时候，口袋里只剩下灰尘。莉兹说，好吧，听着，为什么我不关掉酒吧，带你们所有人去吃早餐。她确实这么做了。
With all the money they'd been giving me.
拿着他们一直给我的钱。
Yeah. And so I remember, at the end of the night, I insulted my best friend Reggie. And I won't go into detail there. But I insulted him, and he got up and he left. And so I was left there in the middle of the Village without a way to get home. And I remember asking Liz if I could borrow $10 to get home. And she obliged. And I thought, now that's my kind of girl.
是的。我记得在夜深时，我侮辱了我最好的朋友雷吉。我不会详述细节。但我侮辱了他，他站起来走了。所以我被留在了村子中间，没法回家。我记得问莉兹我能不能借10块钱回家。她答应了。我想，那才是我的女孩。
It was actually, I gave it to him, because I was sure that I would be able to see him again if he owed me money. And he did come back two days later and gave me the $10 back.
事实上，我给了他，因为我确定如果他欠我钱，我就能再见到他。他两天后确实回来了，把那10块钱还给了我。
Now, is there anything in that first interaction which indicates the overall direction and theme of the way the two of you handle money?
那么，在那第一次互动中有什么迹象表明你们俩处理金钱的整体方向和主题吗？
Just everything. I had never really met somebody before Michael who spent money quite the way that he did. Because I was raised with this incredibly frugal family who always had these amazing anxieties about money. And I was always so amazed when I was hanging out with him. Really, you go to restaurants every day? Or you send your laundry out? And you take taxis everywhere? There's just sort of no-- there didn't seem to be any plan.
简直一切。在迈克尔之前，我从没真正遇到过像他那样花钱的人。因为我是由这个极其节俭的家庭抚养长大的，他们总是对钱有惊人的焦虑。和他在一起时，我总是非常惊讶。真的，你每天都去餐馆？或者你把衣服送出去洗？你到处都打车？简直没有——似乎没有任何计划。
I've had anxiety about money my whole life. It was something that was sort of given to me at a very young age and hasn't ever really been taken away. And so I'm never quite sure that you're not going to starve, or that you're not going to be thrown out on the street.
我一生都在为钱焦虑。这是在很小的时候就给我的东西，从来没有真正被拿走过。所以我从来不确定你不会饿死，或者你不会被扔到街上。
And I've always sort of-- I guess my credo has been that someone will always give you money. Money can come into your life in unexpected ways and in some ways is unpredictable.
我一直有点——我想我的信条是，总会有人给你钱。钱可以以意想不到的方式进入你的生活，在某种程度上是不可预测的。
Would you have conflicts about money, the two of you, earlier on in your relationship?
在你们的关系早期，你们在金钱方面有冲突吗？
Well, I can give you an example. I think probably the biggest money decision and discussion we ever had to have was when we got married. And there was some money that had been put aside for me. My dad had been saving money my whole life for a college education. And for whatever reason, some scholarships, some other stuff, there was a small amount of money left over from that, which he told me I could have when I got married or turned, whatever, 30 or something. I don't remember.
好吧，我可以给你一个例子。我想这可能是有史以来我们要做的最大的金钱决定和讨论是在我们结婚的时候。有一些钱是为我预留的。我爸爸一生都在为我的大学教育存钱。不知何故，一些奖学金，其他一些东西，从那里剩下了一小笔钱，他告诉我，当我结婚或满30岁左右时，我可以拥有它。我不记得了。
And I just knew. I just knew in my heart that my parents' values-- they had gotten married by a Justice of the Peace because it was the frugal thing to do-- because they both have those values, that it's a waste of money to spend money on a wedding.
我只是知道。我内心深处知道我父母的价值观——他们是在和平法官面前结婚的，因为那是节俭的做法——因为他们都有那些价值观，花钱办婚礼是浪费钱。
Wow.
哇。
And I knew. I knew, knew, knew, knew, knew so deeply in my heart that they didn't want me to spend that money on a wedding. And it was kind of the only money that we had at the time. We weren't in debt, but we didn't have any savings. And it was a nice little nest. It would have started off a nice-- you know I mean? For a married couple to have started with this small parcel of money, it would have been good. It also was just enough to have a nice, little wedding, which I wanted but couldn't get over this idea that this money was not to be spent.
我知道。我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道，我内心深处知道他们不希望我把那笔钱花在婚礼上。这是当时我们拥有的唯一的钱。我们没有债务，但我们没有任何积蓄。那是一个不错的窝。它会开启一个美好的——你明白我的意思吗？对于一对已婚夫妇来说，从这小笔钱开始会很好。它也正好足够办一个小而好的婚礼，我想要却无法克服这笔钱不能花的想法。
And Michael was fine, had no qualms at all about spending every last cent of it on the wedding. Because he felt like it was an important thing to, to have everybody that you want with you on this day. And I just couldn't get over it. And it was causing me so much trouble. And we fought about it, I cried about it, we suffered over it. And at one point, I had decided, forget it. We're not spending this money on a big wedding. We'll get married in my parents' backyard. We'll have pulled pork sandwiches and play music on a record player.
迈克尔没问题，一点也不介意把每一分钱都花在婚礼上。因为他觉得在这个日子里让所有你想见的人和你在一起是一件重要的事情。我无法克服它。它给我带来了很多麻烦，我为此哭过，我们为此受过苦。有一次，我决定，算了吧。我们不把这笔钱花在大型婚礼上。我们在我父母的后院结婚。我们吃手撕猪肉三明治，用唱机放音乐。
And then I had this big revelation where I said to Michael, but that means we won't have a band, and that means we won't dance. And what if, for the rest of our lives, whenever we go to a wedding, we see other couples dancing on their wedding day, and every time I see it, it kills me that we didn't get to dance at our wedding?
然后我有了个大启发，我对迈克尔说，但这意味着我们不会有乐队，意味着我们不会跳舞。如果余生中，每当我们去参加婚礼，看到其他夫妇在他们的婚礼当天跳舞，每次我看到它，我们没能在我们的婚礼上跳舞都会让我心碎？
And he got down on his knees, and he took my hands, and he said, I won't tolerate it. I won't tolerate it. We have to spend the money. And we did. And I think that, in many ways, Michael is always just what I needed, as far as showing you what's more important than having $10,000 in the bank.
他跪了下来，握住我的手说，我不会容忍的。我不会容忍的。我们必须花这笔钱。我们确实这么做了。我认为，在很多方面，迈克尔总是我的所需，就展示什么比在银行里有1万美元更重要而言。
Now, if your parents were to tell this story today, would the theme of this story be, and that's when she fell into the hands of the force of evil?
现在，如果你的父母今天讲述这个故事，这个故事的主题会是，“那是她落入邪恶力量之手的时候”吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That was the turning point?
那是转折点？
No, because everything-- the thing that Michael said at the time was, you don't know what's going to happen. Maybe that will be the last $10,000 we'll ever, ever, ever have. Or maybe, six months from now, you'll sell a book, or I'll get a great job, and we'll have tons of money. And we'll look back and we'll say, we could have had the wedding. You should just do what you want to do, because you don't know.
不，因为一切——迈克尔当时说的是，你不知道会发生什么。也许那是我们有史以来最后的一万美元。或者也许，六个月后，你会卖掉一本书，或者我会得到一份好工作，我们会有很多钱。我们会回顾过去说，我们本可以办那场婚礼的。你应该做你想做的事，因为你不知道。
So your parents were fine with the way you spent the money?
所以你父母对你花钱的方式没意见？
Possibly because of the fact that my parents had never had a wedding, it was such an incredibly emotional event for them as well. And of course I would do it all over again. I would do it for $100,000. It was the most beautiful and important day. And the money has never been-- we've never felt its loss for a minute after that. But I really needed to fight to get that feeling, to be able to feel like I deserved to spend $10,000 on one day.
可能是因为我父母从未办过婚礼，这对他们来说也是一件极其感人的事件。当然我会再做一次。即使要花10万美元我也会做。那是最美、最重要的日子。之后我们一分钟也没感觉到损失过。但我真的需要努力去争取那种感觉，能够感觉我值得花一万美元在一天上。
Liz Gilbert is a writer at large for GQ Magazine. Michael Cooper is the director of a human rights foundation.
莉兹·吉尔伯特是《智族》杂志的特约作家。迈克尔·库珀是人权基金会的董事。
[MUSIC - "DIAMONDS AND PEARLS" BY PRINCE]
[音乐 - 王子的《钻石与珍珠》]
Act Four, Pot of Gold. If a windfall can change your life, can your life also be changed by a windfall that you simply believe will occur? We have this story from Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City.
第四幕，金罐。如果横财可以改变你的生活，你的生活也能被你仅仅相信会发生的横财所改变吗？我们有这个来自盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔的故事。
When I was 19, my mother bought an old house for $10,000 and said I could live in it if I cleaned it up and took care of it. It sat in the weeds on a narrow, dead-end alley, two blocks from the University of Utah. I said sure and moved in. Or rather, I opened the door and set my backpack down on the floor.
我19岁时，我妈妈花1万美元买了一栋老房子，说如果我打扫干净并照顾好它，就可以住在里面。它坐落在杂草丛中，在一条窄窄的死胡同里，离犹他大学两个街区。我说好，就搬进去了。或者更确切地说，我打开门，把背包放在地板上。
The first night I was there, my neighbor from across the alley came over for a visit. He was about 45 years old, six foot two, greasy, shoulder-length hair combed straight back, glasses with thick lenses that made his eyes look huge, six-day stubble, black silk shirt, 16-ounce Budweisers in each hand. Welcome to the neighborhood.
我到达的第一晚，我对面胡同的邻居过来拜访。他大约45岁，6英尺2英寸高，油腻的齐肩长发向后梳，戴着厚镜片的眼镜，让眼睛看起来很大，六天的胡茬，黑色丝绸衬衫，每只手拿一罐16盎司的百威啤酒。欢迎来到这个街区。
Down on the corner, he said, you got the two old lesbians. Nosy as hell. A pure nuisance. They just put up two security lights that shine straight in my bedroom. Then next door, there's the crazy hag from Tennessee, drinks Thunderbird all day and screams at her speed freak son to go out and get a job. I've been here longer than anybody. It's my mom's house, but she lives in San Francisco now managing a hotel. The one in that film, The Conversation. You seen it?
在拐角处，他说，有两个老女同性恋。好奇得要命。纯粹的麻烦。她们刚刚安装了两个直射我卧室的安保灯。然后隔壁，有个来自田纳西州的疯老太婆，整天喝雷鸟酒，尖叫着让她那个吸毒成瘾的儿子出去找工作。我在这里待的时间比谁都长。这是我妈的房子，但她现在住旧金山管理一家酒店。那部电影里的那个，《对话》。你看过吗？
Yeah, I said. It's one of my favorites. Harry Caul sleeps in his raincoat. That was an awesome movie, he said. Flushed the bitch down the toilet. No, I said. It turned out that it was all a set-up. And actually the two lovers killed the rich husband. Whatever, he said. The ending was awesome though. The guy playing his saxophone in his apartment.
“看过，”我说。“它是我最喜欢的电影之一。哈里·考尔穿着雨衣睡觉。”“那部电影棒极了，”他说。“把那个婊子冲进厕所。”“不，”我说。“结果发现这一切都是陷阱。实际上是那两个情人杀了富有的丈夫。”“不管怎样，”他说。“结局还是很棒。那个家伙在他的公寓里吹萨克斯管。”
Bob was the type of guy who wanted me to know, first thing, that I could count on him no matter what. Listen, he said, I can tell just by looking at you that you're a smart son of a bitch who doesn't know his ass from his elbow. Probably can't fight worth a damn either. You need anything, you got somebody you want fixed, beat up, or disappeared, whatever, you tell me and it's as good as done. You just ask Bob. Yeah, I said, OK. But things are going pretty good right now. Thanks anyway.
鲍勃是那种想让我第一件事就知道无论发生什么我都能指望他的人。听着，他说，我一看就知道你是个聪明的混蛋，分不清屁股和手肘。可能连架都打不明白。你需要什么，你有什么想搞定、打一顿或消失的人，不管是什么，你告诉我，就像已经做了一样。你尽管问鲍勃。“是的，”我说，“好的。但目前事情进行得还不错。还是谢谢你。”
I gutted the house, tore out any walls that weren't holding up the roof, stripped 12 layers of paper off the others, ripped up the carpet, broke the windows free of paint and opened them for the first time in decades. I kept only the refrigerator and stove and slept on a pad on the floor with a stray kitten on my neck, or on my face, if I'd let it.
我拆了房子，拆掉了所有不支撑屋顶的墙，剥掉了12层壁纸，撕掉了地毯，把窗户从油漆中解放出来，几十年来第一次打开了它们。我只留下了冰箱和炉子，睡在地板上的垫子上，脖子上或脸上带着一只流浪猫，如果我允许的话。
Bob would come over every day and drink beer and smoke Pall Malls and watch me work, offering advice. In the beginning, he had a friend staying with him, Clarence, about 60 years old with white hair, who was just holding up until he went to prison for killing his wife with a broomstick, because she was a witch.
鲍勃每天都会来，喝啤酒，抽帕尔马尔香烟，看着我工作，提出建议。开始时，他有个朋友和他待在一起，克拉伦斯，大约60岁，白头发，只是在因为用扫帚把杀妻（因为他妻子是巫婆）入狱之前待着。
They'd come over with folding lawn chairs, sit and drink beer and listen to jazz on my tape player. They were Bob's tapes. He had John Coltrane, Miles Davis, Ornette Coleman, and older guys like Fats Waller. They'd drink two or three beers. And Bob would get up and move around, not dancing but moving to the music, saying you hear that. You hear that, man? Awesome.
他们带着折叠草坪椅过来，坐着喝啤酒，听我磁带机上的爵士乐。那是鲍勃的磁带。他有约翰·科特兰、迈尔斯·戴维斯、奥尼特·科尔曼，还有像法茨·沃勒这样的老前辈。他们会喝两三罐啤酒。鲍勃会起来走动，不是跳舞，而是随着音乐移动，说“你听到了吗。你听到了吗，伙计？太棒了。”
And it'd go on like this through three beers, four beers. Somewhere around two six-packs they'd be yelling at each other, making no sense whatsoever, while I carried out lath and plaster and threw it in a pile in the front yard.
就这样一直持续到三四罐啤酒。在喝了两打之后，他们会对着对方大喊大叫，毫无意义，而我把板条和石膏运出去，堆在前院。
Clarence did shortly go to prison, the state penitentiary, and even wrote me a letter saying I was a good man and that I should try not to make the same mistakes he had, you know, killing my wife a broomstick. But that all in all, prison wasn't so bad. And that he thanked God every day he wasn't in for lying or cheating or stealing, because these men had nothing to look forward to but getting beat up and being some man's girlfriend.
克拉伦斯确实很快就入狱了，州监狱，甚至写信给我说我是个好人，我不应该犯和他一样的错误，你知道，用扫帚把杀妻。但总而言之，监狱也没那么糟。他每天感谢上帝他不是因为撒谎、欺骗或偷窃而入狱，因为这些人除了被殴打和成为别人的女朋友之外没什么期待。
So Clarence was gone. And the old woman from Tennessee just was no longer around one day. And that just left Bob and me and the two women down on the corner who would sometimes stop by the afternoon, when Bob was sleeping, and ask me all kinds of prying questions. Like, who was my mom anyway to buy this house for me? And why didn't I have a job? And why did I let that Bob come over and bother me?
所以克拉伦斯走了。那个田纳西州的老女人有一天也不再露面了。那只剩下鲍勃和我，以及拐角处那两个女人，有时下午鲍勃睡觉时会过来，问我各种探听问题。比如，我妈到底是谁，居然买这个房子给我？为什么我没有工作？为什么我让鲍勃过来打扰我？
I said, it's true, I don't like his cologne too much. But it gets covered up pretty quick by the cigarettes and beer burps. And then I do actually like his music. Besides, he's lonely. What's wrong with that? He's worthless, they said, absolute garbage.
我说，“确实，他的古龙水味我不太喜欢。但被香烟和啤酒嗝很快就盖住了。而且我确实喜欢他的音乐。此外，他很孤独。那有什么错？”“他一文不值，”她们说，“绝对是垃圾。”
Bob had had jobs, lots of jobs, concrete construction. His last being installing fiberglass insulation. But he'd hurt his back falling off a ladder, and this kept him idled now on disability. The only way he got by at all, he said, was by doing jobs for the man. He wanted me to think that he was a hitman, but I found it hard to believe that Bob could actually kill somebody. He did have a sawed-off shotgun that he kept standing next to his front door. And I used to stare at it and want to pick it up. But I thought it was prop or like a trophy, a way of redeeming himself in the eyes of others.
鲍勃做过工作，很多工作，混凝土施工。最后一份是安装玻璃纤维保温材料。但他从梯子上摔下来伤了背，现在靠残疾补助金闲着。他说他勉强维持生活的唯一方式是为那个人做活。他想让我认为他是杀手，但我发现很难相信鲍勃真的能杀人。他前门旁边确实站着一支锯短的猎枪。我过去常盯着它看，想捡起来。但我以为它是道具，或者是奖杯，一种在他眼中救赎自己的方式。
But then, he did come over one night at 11 o'clock, not even drunk and heavily oiled, looking slick in a black shirt and white tie, clean-shaven. He was shaken. He said he just wanted to say goodbye, as he might not be around for a while. His hand was cold and wet when I shook it.
但后来，他有一天晚上11点过来，甚至没喝醉，油光满面，穿着黑色衬衫和白色领带，刮得干干净净。他很震动。他说他只是想说再见，因为他可能有一阵子不会在这里了。我和他握手时，他的手又冷又湿。
That time, he came back. He was there the next day, sitting in my living room while I was painting. And he never said a thing about what had happened. But a few months later, he was gone for 10 days. And I thought maybe he was on the run. Turned out he'd been in the hospital with a broken leg. He'd gone over to the Top Stop at midnight for a quart of beer and was hit by a drunk driver coming back across 5th East. He had a cast from his crotch to his ankle.
那次，他回来了。第二天他在，坐在我客厅里我正在画画。他没提发生了什么。但几个月后，他消失了10天。我以为他可能在逃亡。结果他在医院，腿断了。他半夜去Top Stop买啤酒，穿过第5东街回来时被一个醉酒司机撞了。他打着从胯部到脚踝的石膏。
I said, I'm sorry man. And he said, no way. It's the best thing that could have happened. Sure, it hurt like a bastard to begin with, but then they shot me up and I was flying. Now I'm going to sue this son of a bitch for everything he has. My lawyer says it'll be in the hundreds of thousands. Maybe a million. I'm rich.
我说，“我很抱歉，伙计。”他说，“没门。这是发生过的最好的事情。当然，一开始痛得要命，但后来他们给我打了针，我就飘了。现在我要起诉这个杂种，拿走他有的一切。我的律师说会有几十万。也许一百万。我是富人了。”
The accident changed Bob's life for the better and for the worse. He decided to go to Trade Tech and study drafting, technical drawing. He had to take some math and do some writing. And he'd come over with his homework and tests to show me how well he was doing. He was proud of himself. He even had a girlfriend for a while, a women his age he'd met at school who was studying to be an accountant. But she turned out to be trouble. But this wasn't the bad part. It wasn't the worst part of hearing he was going to be rich.
事故改变了鲍勃的生活，有好有坏。他决定去贸易技术学校学习绘图、技术制图。他不得不学习一些数学和写作。他会带着作业和考试来向我展示他做得多好。他为自己感到骄傲。甚至有一段时间有一个女朋友，他在学校认识的同龄女性，正在学习成为会计。但她被证明是个麻烦。但这并不是听到他要致富的最糟糕的部分。
As soon as Bob's lawyer told him he was going to be rich, he started to think about what he was going to do with all the money, how he was going to spend it. He had a list on paper. Two Harley Davidsons, an Electra Glide and a Sportster, and a pick-up truck to haul them around in, a new four-way stereo system with a 500-watt Kenwood amplifier and six-foot high JBL loudspeakers, an elaborate hand-carved bar for drinking and entertaining his friends, and a new home.
律师告诉他要致富后，他开始思考他要用钱做什么，他要怎么花。他纸上有一张清单。两辆哈雷戴维森，一辆Electra Glide和一辆Sportster，还有一辆皮卡车来装它们，一套带有500瓦建伍放大器和六英尺高JBL扬声器的新四向音响系统，一个用于喝酒和招待朋友的精致手刻吧台，还有一个新家。
Or rather, he'd rebuild his present home, a small brick box, by first raising it 15 feet off the ground on steel I-beams and installing an electronic trap door for an entrance. Then he was going to take off his roof and add another three floors on top, pagoda style. He had it drawn out in all dimensions and angles. A 60-foot tall pagoda with dragons and flames that would flare out from sloping gables, everything in detail, down to the framing and nailing schedules.
或者更确切地说，他将重建目前的家，一个小砖箱，首先用钢工字梁将其抬高15英尺，并安装一个电子活板门入口。然后他要拆掉屋顶，在上面再加三层，宝塔风格。他把它画得清清楚楚，所有的尺寸和角度。一座60英尺高的宝塔，龙和火焰从倾斜的三角墙突出，一切都很详细，直到框架和钉接进度表。
He had these drawings laid out on his kitchen table. And he carried the list of things to buy in his shirt pocket, so he could add and subtract continually, day by day, month by month, on and on. It became a notebook, then several notebooks. And to me, it was like he had a disease, a mental illness, where these things, all these things had gone, in his mind, from being objects of desire to actual, material things already in his possession. He kept his hair cut. He changed his clothes. He stopped with the cologne. He stopped coming over and spending the day. He was a new man, because he had all this stuff. But then he didn't actually have any of it.
他把这些图纸铺在厨房桌子上。他在衬衫口袋里放着购买清单，这样他可以日复一日、月复一月地不断加减。它变成了一个笔记本，然后是几个笔记本。对我来说，就像他患了病，精神病，这些东西，所有这些东西，在他的脑海里，从渴望的对象变成了他实际拥有的物质东西。他保持头发整洁。他换了衣服。他不再用古龙水。他不再过来消磨时光。他是个新人，因为他有这一切。但后来他实际上什么都没有。
The lawsuit dragged on and on, one year, two years. And in the end, he got very little, maybe a few thousand dollars, as the lawyer's bill came to quite a lot, I guess. And then the judge decided that Bob's life hadn't really been damaged so much after all. He'd been a bum, essentially, before the accident. And after the accident, he'd earned a degree in technical drawing, and was actually something better than a bum. So I think it was difficult to justify a large compensation.
诉讼拖了又拖，一年，两年。最后，他得到了很少的钱，也许几千美元，因为我想律师费相当贵。然后法官决定，鲍勃的生活并没有真正受到那么大的损害。事故前他本质上是个流浪汉。事故后，他获得了技术制图学位，实际上比流浪汉好。所以我认为很难证明有巨大的赔偿。
But then I don't really know what happened, as Bob was too sad and depressed to talk about it. Then one day he was gone. He left me a note saying he went to San Francisco to live with his mother and didn't know when he'd be back. I moved on as well not long after that to go to school out of state. And I've never seen or heard from him since. I hope he's still not carrying that list. I picture him sitting in the basement of the Jack Tar Hotel, the one in the movie, with a lousy mattress and a sawed-off shotgun, listening to Miles and waiting to be called upstairs by the man for a job, disposing of the evidence by flushing it down the toilet.
但后来我真的不知道发生了什么，因为鲍勃太悲伤和沮丧而无法谈论它。然后有一天他走了。他留了张字条给我，说他去旧金山和他妈妈住，不知道什么时候回来。我没过多久也搬走了，去外州上学。从那以后我再也没见过或听过他的消息。我希望他还没带着那张清单。我想象他坐在杰克塔酒店的地下室里，电影里的那家，带着一张破烂的床垫和一支锯短的猎枪，听着迈尔斯，等待着那个人叫他上去做活，通过把证据冲进厕所来处理掉。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City.
盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell.
好的，我们的节目今天由阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德协助。特约编辑，保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Alex Blumberg did our interview today with the lottery winner, Todd Powell, at the top of the show. If you'd like to buy a cassette of our program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格今天在节目开头对彩票中奖者托德·鲍威尔进行了采访。如果你想买我们节目的磁带，请打我们在芝加哥WBEZ的电话，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址是 [email protected] 。或者你知道你可以在我们的网站 www.thislife.org 上免费收听我们的大部分节目。《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who said this, when he discovered that i'd bought all that new equipment for the studio without telling him--
WBEZ管理层由托里·马拉蒂亚监管，他发现了我在没告诉他的情况下为工作室购买了所有这些新设备后说了这样一句话——
Honey, what is this?
甜心，这是什么？
I'm Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Well, how did this get in your closet, then?
那么这东西是怎么进你壁橱的？
Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
下周回来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共电台。